وجهت القوات الامريكيه ضربات لمواقع في
سوريا والعراق في اول رد على مقتل ثلاثه
جنود امريكيين بالهجوم الذي استهدف
قاعدتهم شمال شرقي الاردن الاحد الماضي
وقالت واشنطن ان المواقع تضم منشات تابعه
للحرس الثوري الايراني وفيلق القدس فيما
قال مصدر امني عراقي ان ثلاثه عسكريين
ومدنيين قتلوا واصيب نحو 15 اخرين كحصن
اوليه للقصف امريكي وقال الحشد الشعبي ان
القصف استهدف مقر قياده عمليات الانبار
للحشد ومخازن الاسلحه في منطقه السكك
بقضاء
القائم وفي سوريا استهدفت الضربات
الامريكيه اهدافا في دير الزور حيث قال
التلفزيون السوري الرسمي ان الطيران
الحربي الامريكي استهدف قريه عياش بريف
دير الزور الغربي وفي مدينه دير الزور
مركز
المحافظه استهدفت ضربات كلا من حويجه صقر
وسط مدينه دير الزور اضافه الى مطار دير
الزور العسكري في ريف دير الزور الشرقي
استهدف القصف الامريكي حي التم في مدينه
الميادين ومنطقه الشبلي وعين علي في
محيطها وفي باديه محافظه حمص وسط سوريا
استهدف الطيران محطه الضخ الثالثه في
باديه مدينه تدمر اما عند الحدود السوريه
العراقيه فجاءت الضربات على حي الهجانه
غربيه مدينه البوكمال وعلى قريه الهري في
محيطها